sticking within the dc film franchise i  don't even know if you're involved in  this  but because you are directing feature  films now i'm wondering what your take  is on the new cut  of justice league just in terms of i  don't know maybe just the value of  getting a  different cut of a film that was already  released in theaters is there anything  about that process that excites you  um i don't know enough about that  situation i never saw justice league  um  i don't even know if we got cut out of  it anyway what i do  think i know maybe i have the news  incorrect but  um because uh the director had a  tragedy happen in his personal life  which we know right  and they basically i think  took the film away from him i could have  that wrong  and i i have to say with what little i  know  if this is that director's vision again  and if this was the story that was  signed off on  and he's finally able to bring that to  fruition power to him  you